the lesson page
the lesson page is split into two parts
in the dashboard on the right you can
find a variety of information about the
lesson
you can listen to the audio and keep
track of your activity
the blue new words tab displays all the
new words in the lesson
the yellow links tab shows all of your
saved words in this lesson
in the info tab you can follow the
growth of your avatar you can also see
statistics related to each lesson
you can minimize the dashboard by
clicking the button at the top right
this makes it easier to review lessons
when using a smaller screen on the left
hand side you will find the lesson text
new words are shown in blue
if you encounter a new word just click
on it you can select one of the hints
that are displayed
and save it
if you prefer you can click on search
dictionary to find a new definition in
the dictionary
once a word is saved it will turn yellow
we call this creating a link
if you already know a word you may want
to click known to add it to your known
words total
you can also leave new words blue and
convert all remaining words to known at
the bottom of the lesson page
vocabulary all the links you have
created are found in the vocabulary
section
in the vocabulary section you can review
your links using a variety of vocabulary
review tests you can also edit links and
adjust their status
each day you will be sent a list of
links to review in what is called the
links of the day email
if you have an ios or android device you
can use your ilink app
this app allows you to study flash cards
review your lessons and create playlists
to listen to on the go
to download the app
click on the icon at the bottom of the
page